hey guys i'm back in toronto i had to
come home in a bit of a rush
most of this video is from about a month
ago when i caught the delta variant
of kovid in moscow i wanted to make this
into a video because i've been vocal
about how kovitt has been handled and
how i've been against lockdowns and
vaccination passports etc as a lot of my
audience is disagreeable and skeptical
like me i thought they should know what
my experience of covid was like
keep in mind this is the second time
i've had it
overall it was quite unpleasant
significantly worse than the first time
around
i was unbelievably weak i had a wheeze
for about 10 days
a cough for a few days brain fog anxiety
my skin broke out
but mainly serious muscle fatigue and
weakness if i wasn't a healthy person
i'd actually be worried about how bad
that could have been for me
i will be waiting to get the vaccine
until there's a bit more evidence that
it's safe
and we'll see how i feel in six months
but the experience was definitely
unpleasant enough this time
that i would consider getting the
vaccine like i've said before
i'm not anti-vaxx i'm just skeptical of
new medical procedures
and my overly sensitive immune system's
response to said new medical procedures
i'll probably consider getting it in
four to six
months or so when my current immunity
wears off and more time is passed to
judge potential side effects of the
vaccine
however i can tell you the side effects
of this new variant of covid
were unpleasant so here's my experience
it's a bit disorganized
because i was super brain foggy the
whole time i'm better now
i'm just mainly tired but
life is a little bit tiresome sometimes
so i hope you enjoy
thought i might as well film this turns
out i have covid
second time which is where the
government isn't lying about everything
did you have covet again huh is
different than last time
uh andre has it he got tested at a
russian clinic and the doctor basically
said
the second time around because you have
some immunity it's less bad
so she said it's about four days i had
a serious achy body today yesterday i
was sick too
i had a fever i sounded like a zombie
about two hours ago my nose has just
been like
running water uh i've i've
probably sneezed 40 times today so
i'm not going outside to infect other
people although the entirety of russia
obviously has it
shocker and
well i don't know hopefully this only
lasts four days i did sound bad enough i
did two podcasts this week
i sounded bad enough a couple of hours
ago that i cancelled
the next ones so hopefully i can sleep
but i don't know i wouldn't have got
tested andre actually went to the doctor
for something else and they were like do
you want to cover test
so we will see how long this lasts this
is day
two this is what i sound like
it occurred to me this morning that
about two weeks ago scarlett had
a cough and a fever fever for a few days
and then a cough for about five days
a pretty like a long
cough and so that's probably where this
came from
this is definitely worse than the first
round of covet i had in serbia last year
it turns out moscow's being overtaken by
the delta variant
so the variant thing that we're being
told by the media
is definitely true i feel better today
i sound much worse but i feel better
today than i did yesterday
i had a fever all day yesterday and i
don't have a fever anymore
although i seem to have some lung action
going on
i would say i wanted to make this video
because
i've been fairly vocal about covet etc
about what we're being told is real and
what isn't real
and this delta variant is definitely a
little bit i would be concerned if i
wasn't
fairly healthy like if uh when i was on
immune suppressants i used to get
bronchitis every year
and it was terrible and so if my immune
system was compromised in any way
or i was an older person i'd probably be
a bit concerned about the delta variant
i don't think it's going to last very
long the doctor
told us that because we had coven and we
have some immunity
similar to being vaccinated
that when you get the delta variant or
you get it again it only lasts about
four days
scarlet had symptoms for longer than
four days so i don't know if that's true
but yeah we'll see
i'm not stuck in bed yesterday i was
really achy really uncomfortable i'm
actually feeling better today but it's
gotten like
my skin's breaking out that happened
last time my wrist is sore
i always get arthritis whenever i get
some sort of virus
and my nose has just been like leaking
water basically been sneezing i would
like to say
this one is unpleasant enough that
yesterday i was like dude this if i had
known this was going to come
maybe i would have looked at the vaccine
i hadn't been looking at the vaccine
because i already had coven was like why
would i
why would i get it if i already had
coven
there's evidence that having two
vaccines can reduce the likelihood that
you're going to get this delta
or reduce the severity of the disease i
would be concerned like i said
if i was an older person or somebody who
wasn't in
really good health to to get this
i know there haven't been studies done
on mrna vaccines for very long
but this is unpleasant that being said
there's also evidence that prior
infection reduces the severity of delta
because you have some
immunity built up so
hopefully this is only four days because
this is a pain just to give an example
of this being serious
see it's really not great and i'm
healthy
looks like i coughed all the mucus away
and now i sound more like a normal
person
i don't mean to be fear-mongering i'm
going to be fine scarlet's fine
andre's over it already it's just me
but people who aren't healthy should get
healthy because
it's fairly serious so
get healthy probably get vaccinated if
you're not going to get healthy
or it's going to suck coping day five
i put makeup on put contacts in feeling
more alive
my nose is just a little bit stuffy and
i'm
at 90 normal again so hopefully in a few
days i'll have a negative test
so i recorded a podcast today i was
extremely exhausted all day
like weak exhausted i have a cough that
goes off and on in my lungs
how many wheeze right now but i
certainly did earlier and i'm
mostly i'm just exhausted also i have no
taste
no taste i can't taste i mean i only eat
like two things
so it's it's not that much of a loss
really but i can taste salt if there's a
lot of it
and i've been eating honey i can eat
honey now
without having autoimmune symptoms and
it's hard to tell
if this is glue or honey
and to be fair i'm in russia so it
really could be glue
sorry any russian watching this that's a
joke it's a joke at your expense
no i can taste honey a tiny bit but it's
amazing
how much taste i've lost so hopefully
that comes back but
there's this piece of hair doing but if
it doesn't
i only like three things anyway so who
cares
right [ __ ] it at this point day eight
i've coped
i just did another podcast i'm exhausted
mainly yeah
my nose still kind of burns it's where
this covet has like
burning my eye was burning today like my
nate the
nasal passages or whatever they're up
here it felt like my eye was burning
if i do that it hurts a bit of a cough
and this is like day eight so i hope
this doesn't last forever because it's
getting pretty boring i'm
really exhausted physically weak
and tired it's gonna be two weeks
tomorrow that i still have coping
this is stretching out i was wheezing
yesterday i'm still coughing
my nose is still stuffy i'm gonna get
tested in two days to see if it's
i'm negative at least but this is a huge
pain i've been
physically exhausted
it sucks and i'm healthy and it still
sucks so i'm covered negative
see this that is an instant covered test
stuck very far up both my nostrils
put on to here no covet my nose is still
a bit stuffy
i'd like a bit of mucus in my lungs but
apparently i have no covet anymore
and i'm going home and i don't have to
do the hotel quarantine because
i had a positive cova test in the last
14 to 90 days
so something that makes sense shocking
overall i would not recommend
the delta variant of copid it sucked it
really did suck i was
so unbelievably weak muscle-wise for
like
a solid 10 days it was crazy i was
walking half a block i was like
oh and about i think i recorded it a few
days ago i was like if this keeps up i'm
going to the doctor
i don't know what they're gonna do but
this
sucks and then two days later it just
turned off
i feel 95 back to normal now
so that was how many days
realistically
oh was that really only a week
was that only eight days was it 15 days
it was definitely 15 days yeah okay so
it lasted a while 15 days uh 14 13. i
would say 13 days
of bad symptoms but now i'm immune
but it sucked it really did suck so
if the vaccine does not make anybody
grow
third arms or become infertile
it's something to probably consider i
will most likely be considering it once
there's a little bit more evidence
and i'm a little bit more comfortable
with it as much fun as new vaccines are
i'm a skeptical human being but
if things look good in six months or a
year or so
i'll probably consider getting it if
covet is still a problem
because that really was pretty nasty
so i hope you enjoyed my covet delta
variant
movie experience
talk to you guys soon